you don't meet these sort of people
every day you know but I met Bollywood
stars in there I met certain big big
very big gangsters and because they was
obviously kept separate it was a high
security if you like
area about 2011 actually somebody came
they was extradited from
Thailand uh it was a gangster from the
90s called Santos shetta he was brought
in uh speaks very good English we become
very good friends we ended up staying
together in the same
cell and I got for for two years I sort
of lived like a king if you can call it
that in the jail you know everybody knew
me because of him and I go to court and
the guards had let me wonder around for
a few hours because of him could bring
things in you know so life was sort of
okay at that point okay as can be
considering the situation you know